des jeunes de talent comme ici nathalie
anne sadallah espère en découvrir de
plus en plus dans son île natale
retrouver sa longue et riche vie
d'artiste dans l'hexagone côtés
notamment de jean albany constitue une
expérience considérable dont elle espère
faire profiter les autres
avec son association débit bongo elle
entame en quelque sorte la deuxième
partie de sa carrière artistique bébé
bongo pourquoi baby boom boom est ce qu
a une histoire attaché au nom de
l'association très très c'est mon
histoire dans l'après non ce que mon nom
d'artiste que le député pendant des
années des années
ça m'a porté chance et je me suis
toujours dit si demain je dois faire
quelque chose face nous menacent et
délits bongo il ya toujours des petits
sont autour de moi et voilà donc vu
c'est ce qui vous amène un petit peu a
continué son courroux
oui vous continuez mais vous ne dansez
vous ne chantez peut-être moi oui mais
je peux chanter les autres je vais
danser les autres actuellement
d'association à ce qui est des jeunes
artistes en herbe
oui justement l'association il ya
nathalie 1 - 1 qu' une petite l'artiste
sont allés mais artiste 1 et d'une
famille musicienne
il y a
son pea qui écrit des chansons qui est
auteur compositeur elle change depuis
tout petit et à l'âge de neuf ans son
père l'a pris en d'accord vraiment parce
que on a vu vraiment on peut faire
quelque chose avec nathalie elle a
chanté dans les radios crochets à
remporter des prix elle a voyagé aussi
voilà
et ça fait maintenant la sortie son
premier maxi cd
là je prépare actuellement ça me fait
plaisir
voilà qu'est ce que vous avez apporté à
nathalie si par exemple bombay son
premier podium j'étais à ses côtés son
premier disque otages et à son côté
première radio j'étais assez à son côté
et dans l'association
justement vous occuper des jeunes oui
les détectives si oui tout ça est ce
qu'il ya qu'est ce qu'on peut trouver
dans l'association don mais la danse la
danse le chant ce que j'aime bien aussi
à prendre les enfants réciter des poèmes
accord oui s'agit de ça c'est
l'affluence de pygmalion aux liens sur
le typhon il faut qu'ils ont récité un
poème c'est de préférence de préférence
au m2 qui déjà albanie d'accord nuit est
ce que les enfants acceptent
ben ça seulement ils disaient ils
comprennent pas les part j'ai dit moi
aussi à l'époque qu'on connaît pas par
exemple je chantais ses chansons toinou
300 dragon d'or montpetit encore mal à
pagny sylvie souvient afrique comme ati
jeans et des chansons que je sais mais
je comprends pas qu'au niveau du texte
que d'aix et plus la mélodie qui était
de monde de rivel qui était comme mon
âge
oui oui oui par exemple aujourd'hui bon
je vais interpréter un petit par exemple
la fuite comme totti dit mais oui
monsieur le convainc pas gouki pantaly
nikunau giambi compte les palois nos de
bengali mais oui et sur le compte
l'apab ou qui portent à l'est
me dis qu'au bout du compte me pèse pas
trop bec ali afrik com vote idi la
longue l'été linga bourdages l'avant
gauche ila membres élevée à l'écart
ça a été une rencontre très importante
pour représente pour autant très très
important c'était quand je rencontre les
gens le banni pour moi c'était le père
le frère et la lie il m'emmenait pas
prendre ma chanter à danser
enfin suivent un petit peu la culture
entre temps je chantais j'ai dansé
toujours avec des bus d'autres caisses
mais c'était tellement pas trop trop
porté sur les gens sont de jean albany
pas ce que c'est et les chansons très
très dur mais il me disait tu vas y
arriver
tu est fait pour ça c'est ça le jeu télé
kréol tesat et ça il y avait des paroles
par exemple bang adorent la dinb la benz
usa
j'arrive pas à comprendre mais qu'est ce
que dit la litanie cause et rigoler et
souvent aussi quand par exemple on
allait faire des galas il était l'un
s'était pas par un âne çà çà çà que
comporte tout ça et ça ça j'étais pas
d'accord ok parce que sinon moi j'avais
la lance du n'importe quoi vous parlez
de votre vie d'artiste vous avez été
artiste voulait toujours confiant est-ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter un petit
peu votre carrière
et bien voilà j'ai quitté
avec tout juste j'avais pas encore 18
ans oui c'était dans l'année 1965
je suis par le demi d'hommes comme tous
les jeunes de mon âge je vais arriver là
bas on s'était créé dû à l'époque
en tout les réunionnais se retrouver à
l'époque au foyer là j'ai eu mon premier
mondial premier contact avec aimé tes
chers c'était quelqu'un de paris le
biodôme il avait monté le groupe
folklorique bon danser on chantait tout
ça en faisait des six toiles et tout ça
m'a toujours plu vous dire je t'ai
toujours le boute-en-train
ensuite j'en ai mais dans les foyers
allez j'ai animé les haqqani dit oui à
l'époque artistes on disait artus
d'accord parce qu'on aimait ça voilà moi
je suis devenu vraiment triste parce que
quand je suis devenu vraiment artistes
c'était en 72 en continu un petit peu
vos déplacements comment ça se passait
ben quand j'étais sur paris avec maxime
dont faisait c'était moi je te gâcher le
tout d'accord ça va être à celle que
j'ai dansé chanté et
c'était un trio quoi bon là il y avait
caché avec gérard peliks et ailes d'ange
délivre donc là aussi avait de cacher
les tailles du côté de chant c'était
tout le temps bénévolat mais niveau là
je me suis dit non on ne peut pas y
arriver comme ça je me suis complètement
du côté de la danse et en 72 là je suis
parti je vous dirai jamais et j'ai vu
changer des gens ça y est je peux pas
continuer à chanter c'est un peu
embêtant mais la chanson me donne ne
paye pas d'accord et quand je vais dans
ses eaux
j'ai des cachets il m'a dit ma petite
plus fait je sais ce que tu vois que tu
peux fait à quoi
mais si tu prends la danse ne retourne
jamais en arrière continu continu
continu jeudi d'accord et qu'en même
temps at rester en italie de 72 jusqu'à
92 parce que dès que je suis arrivé là
bas j'ai cette chance de rencontrer des
françaises qui me dit hans avaient très
très dur alors surtout fais toi tout de
suite allons d'artiste je dis pourquoi
requis s'est ainsi inscrit toi de suite
parce que dans le contrat et à payer
l'assurance vieillesse assurance maladie
les dix poissons l'imprésario
l'hôtel le manger le voyage tout ça tu
payes jeunes idée reste plus rien dit qu
paix et que tu t'en souviendras alors
j'ai dit oui mais quand on a déjà enlevé
tout ça il reste plus rien c'est à
prendre ou à laisser
et c'est ce que j'ai fait aussitôt après
avoir fait vingt ans de carrière et 2700
points
parce que c'était toi quand j'avais eu
quand j'ai une savent gérer unis paraît
dans tout l'est dans l'europe et dans
les temps pour les endroits quand même
et même en amérique centrale travailler
partout je suis parti j'avais tous ces
points et vingt ans après je suis parti
à rome j'ai dit voilà j'ai tout ce qu'il
faut
ils ont ils ont mis un an un an et demi
a cherché tout une saillie vous en avez
qu'est ce que vous faites jeudi je veux
ma pré retraite dit bon on vous donne
votre retraite mais vous allez signer un
papier comme quoi vous montez plus sur
la piste je dis pas de problème après
predator qu'est-ce que vous avez
remarqué le plus justement dans ce pays
et de ce monde médical mais ce que j'ai
beaucoup remarqué c'est à dire que l'on
était tous des étrangers
je travaille avec beaucoup d étrangers
il y avait cette harmonie il y avait
cette solidarité d'accord alors avec
tout ce qu'on était présente dans un
pays qui est pas le nôtre
alors tout le monde se donner la main et
ce qui était bien ça fait mal au moral
mangez pas souffert de ça vous avez été
bien accueillie avec très très très très
très très aujourd'hui si on vous demande
de faire le bilan un petit peu de cette
ville
d'artistes il avait eu en métropole est
ce que vous considérez que c'était plus
la galère où ça a été les découvertes
des choses qu'on dise quoi mais je
dirais une gale et adoré parce que j'ai
choisi
c'était dur mais il y avait la danse le
chant je t'ai pas l'arrêt que la vie
familiale j'étais pas là avec ça il
fallait il pas les suivent
quand vous étiez en métropole de par le
monde
puisque vous n'avez pas été qu'en
métropole où il peut faire un peu
partout qu'est ce qui vous a manqué le
plus bas c'était pour dire depuis 65 ans
94e jamais su ce que c'était noël joie
de l'an répète plus jamais su sage pour
moi ça s'est passé
on commence à découvrir ma première la
première web que j'ai fait là ma vie ici
à la réunion c'était cette année deux
nuls avec nathalie m
voilà ça que vous a manqué ça m'a
beaucoup moins que j'avais plus que
c'était noël
est ce que aujourd'hui vous pouvez dire
que vous ne regrettez pas du tout deux
parties dit non je réussis à
michel debré et je suis j'ai la chance
de chanter de danser pour lui aimerait
oublier ça s'est passé
apparu en 71 pour la fête du 1er mai
parce que pour l'instant vous avez une
aide d'une aide précieuse à vos côtés ça
a toujours été depuis tout petit jusqu'à
maintenant je tiens à remercier à ma
soeur madame arlette souris c'est elle
qui m'a toujours encouragé qui m'a
toujours eddie pons c'est bien ce que tu
fais elle ne vous dis pas seulement
fausses elles vous êtes de quelle
manière moralement on est moralement
j'ai beau j'ai besoin ça oui j'ai besoin
sans la moindre chose que quand quelque
chose ça va pas je dis arlette telle ou
telle façon
elle est là pour me conseiller est là
pour me diagne on sait sa série après
jean albani qui avait arlette